[Music]
until 9/11 Jonestown was the scene of
America's worst humanitarian disaster a
dam burst up River
and more than 2,000 people were drowned
in the ensuing flood there been other
floods since then indeed it epitomizes
the struggle of blue-collar Americans to
such an extent that Johnstown is named
checked in to Bruce Springsteen songs
but having followed his democratic
politics for decades
Johnstown is now swinging in the other
direction towards Donald Trump
this specialist business has enjoyed
some of its best years under President
Obama and all the books are filling up
again yet there's still a mood but
they're ready for a change
and whirring what do you think about
President Obama were you fine or not I
actually owe you fear I actually voted
for him actually with the same speech
but he came here me and my wife got a
book he autographed it for her
so yeah we were for him and we recently
switched my party the Republican I used
to be Democrat I switch Republican why
tired the same old stuff I mean there
has been a real change in in
Pennsylvania you know because it's been
was democratic for a long time well I
agree I know what you're saying there
and I just feel that uh Trump coming in
is more of a businessman so in the
prospect of business I'm sure he'll do
some great things there is a lot of
picturesque old metal around but to call
this area the Rust Belt isn't really
fair
Johnstown has been at the center of the
island steel trade for more than 300
years and it continues to have many
thriving businesses within it people in
Europe try to understand the election of
Donald Trump and there's a lot of talk
about you know blue-collar Rust Belt
rural versus city liberals of all
arrested do you think that's a sensible
way of looking at it I think it's the I
think it's a realistic way of looking at
it the larger cities you have a lot of
people in one area and a lot of those
people have the same viewpoints when you
get out into the rural communities such
as Johnstown we were always strictly
Democrat but during the last election
John Trump won Johnson and I think
that's more people just tired of the
bureaucracy so hope rather than
expectation but as one person here said
away from the microphones at least
Trump's election has shown a light on us
and we needed that
[Music]
you